[Music]
foreign
[Music]
coming at you from the basement Studio
we're back uh this is clearly not your
regularly scheduled programming
um fortunately I'm cooped up here
because I finally caught covid two years
or I should say kovid finally caught me
two years in uh don't worry not to worry
I'm fine I've actually long recovered
I'm just waiting to test negative a few
times in a row before I go back into the
studio trying to be smart and safe about
it but while I am cooped up down here
I'm just kind of like there's not much
around so I can't do much with the
typical Studio stuff what can I do and
my idea that I had was I'm gonna share
some uh some opinions that I have
that could be considered hot takes some
spicy hot takes for you real things that
I actually believe at the end of 2022.
so I haven't done this before this might
this might ruffle some feathers
obviously I think we've sort of done a
little bit of this on the waveform
podcast probably a little more actually
on the studio Channel I remember we had
a segment where we all gave our our Tech
hot takes uh but you know forgive the
production quality this is me and a
camera and a Yeti mic which is not even
meant to be held like this I just happen
to have this mic here while I'm home so
anyway uh we'll see if y'all agree with
me or not on any of this stuff but let's
uh let's just jump right into it so
number one for me
crypto investing
is basically all just gambling so look
look I know I'm the I'm supposed to be
the tech person I'm very optimistic
typically about technology and so I'm
always trying to see uh the potential
future of web3 and nfts and the
blockchain and and Bitcoin and ethereum
and all this stuff uh but I'd still
consider myself a skeptic because it's
so hard to see through all of the noise
is what I think is a charitable way of
calling it so much noise I actually got
asked recently on Dr Mike's podcast and
it was funny that's like one of the
first times I've actually been asked
publicly about crypto in a while but he
asked me about what I think about it and
here's what I said how involved or
interested are you in the nft space or
crypto space
as close to zero as you can be without
being zero I have to like keep an eye on
it but I have so much skepticism in like
me too every time something gets pitched
in the inbox or in person or I see
anything
it always just defaults to how much
money you can make and I need to know
some other benefits yes yes anything
tangible like how useful it'll be I've
seen a little bit some whisperings here
and there about like maybe the deed of
your house will be an nft one day maybe
I don't know I have a safe with a deed
in it I feel like an old person when I
say this but like
I'm skeptic
I'm a thousand percent with you yeah and
that is still for me a hundred percent
true do I own some crypto still yeah I
do how much doesn't really matter
because I can't use it for anything I
mean you do see the headlines once in a
while right every once in a while a
couple months you'll see a headline
about a new business that's like
starting to accept Bitcoin or ethereum
or some crypto or something like that I
remember Tesla did this briefly and then
they stopped and I was like that
headline surfaces every couple months
and I notice it and I wait for the
Fallout and the continuation but it just
never happens and so basically what's
happened is all of this promise of like
this decentralized world of the future
of crypto and nfts and all this stuff
it's it's just promise for me and it's
all been reduced to like when I open my
inbox and I see a new crypto pitch every
single time it's just about how much
money you can make if you invest if you
buy the price goes up and then you make
money
but what else what other reasons I need
other reasons so I'll continue to hold
the the Bitcoin that I have it's fine
it's not even that much but I think for
me if I can't explain why something is
more valuable other than lots of people
are interested in it right now so it's
kind of hot so the value is up there's
nothing else to it
then uh it's as good as gambling to me
so okay number two my number two hot
take
um is actually just that Tick Tock and
YouTube can and will co-exist they'll
both be completely fine now maybe this
is just a little less spicy than the
others but I mean every time I get asked
about Tick Tock one of the biggest
questions I hear a lot is like should
YouTube be worried you know the massive
massive rise of tick tock over the past
few years especially with the pandemic
has been gargantuan you feel like it's
unavoidable that this overlap that that
Tick Tock just comes up and just starts
eating YouTube's lunch but I think the
key thing still for YouTube and and Tick
Tock is they are such different use
cases that they don't overlap at all I
mean a tiny bit maybe of your time but
almost not at all on YouTube what's this
a YouTube video right you go to YouTube
to sit down and actually spend some time
watching a video that you either
searched for or was recommended to you
on the homepage and you chose it to
watch it you spend more time per her
video on YouTube it's got a whole search
engine attached to it so you'll find
videos based on what you're interested
in and and Tick Tock is like I'll sit
down and I'll have like two minutes or
something and you'll just open it up and
scroll a few times and then close it and
that's it you just get that quick
dopamine burst that quick adrenaline
boost that instant gratification
and you never actually choose the videos
you want to watch it just gets sort of
served to you so it kind of reminds me
of like YouTube and Netflix YouTube is
the world's online video library but
Netflix while it is technically also an
online video library
is different and you expect different
things in different places and so they
can coexist and that's totally fine
that's why I think tick tock's also just
going to have a huge separate pie it's
not taking a slice of YouTube's pie it's
just a new pie and I think with YouTube
Shorts YouTube responded pretty
correctly and also offering a competing
product to tick tock because you know it
is related and I also managed to beat
tick tock's monetization model like
right off the bat very quickly they
offer Revenue sharing as of either right
now or they're about to start where Tick
Tock is still stuck on the Creator you
know pool that everyone draws money from
so bottom line they're going to be fine
they're separate pies and you can stop
asking me that that's not that's not
that hot of a take actually okay number
three
number three
regular people
don't care about panel gaps
they just don't care and that's I'm
talking about Tesla right now of course
so one of the biggest things you always
hear in car reviews when people talk
about Tesla and compare it to other cars
especially you hear this in the
Enthusiast community and in in reviews a
lot is oh my God the panel gaps the
panel gaps the build quality in this car
is terrible the gap between the panel
here on the hood and on the door is
bigger than this gap between these
panels and it's smaller than the gap
between these panels it's so
inconsistent it's jarring it's a poor
build and that's actually
true that's actually true about Tesla's
cars they're much less consistent than
the manufacturers who have been
established and who have learned to
refine their processes over the past 50
hundred plus years but this to me
reminds me of I'm sure there's an
equivalent in the smartphone world where
like reviewers notice this maybe it's
like refresh rate on screens I don't
know reviewers notice this and really
care about it and harp on it a lot but
guess what at the end of the day people
are still buying Teslas and it's just
because the the panel gaps are so low on
the list of things that you think about
when you're buying a car that it happens
to still be fine like this is similar
with McLaren McLaren is notorious for
obviously other electrical issues and
build quality issues but McLarens are
all these beautiful hand-built sports
cars and you often will see sizable gaps
sizable differences in panel gaps on
McLarens but guess what people still
love their McLarens because that is
really far down on the list on why
someone was looking at and thinking
about buying a 765lt but the thing is I
want Tesla to get better at this like
having panel gaps is not good in your
cars and they've had all kinds of
notorious build quality issues in the
past as they've aged they got out of
building in a tent and they've been
working towards improving on their way
to the likes of the German manufacturers
and the others uh how do you how do you
get around this and I think really I
look at it like this this is how I look
at it right now if you could buy a model
3 but you had to trade some other
feature from the model 3 from a
different car that's really well built
like okay Tesla Model 3 versus Mustang
Mach e you could have a Tesla Model 3
with perfect panel gaps everything about
the build quality of the car looks like
it was built by Ford but you have to
trade something with the Ford you trade
Tesla's supercharger Network and you get
Ford's public open access charger
Network we would you take that Tesla
no actually I wouldn't because obviously
the supercharger network is a huge part
of why people end up buying a Tesla so
okay what about you get the perfect
Tesla Model 3 but you get the Ford's
software
and would you take that no I think most
people still would probably take the
Tesla with the panel gaps and you just
keep going down the list would you take
the Tesla Model 3 with no panel gaps but
trade something else about it you find
performance is it the tires is it the
paint something something else about it
and I think what you'll find is that
most people will take the Tesla as is
with its current set of features so
basically I think Tesla Tesla's done the
math and they will continue to focus on
the things that they believe are reasons
why people do buy their cars so
differentiating themselves on the
Battery Technology on the drivetrains on
supercharger Network for that matter on
their software on all these other things
and the second that panel gaps and
Manufacturing issues meaningfully impact
their bottom line then and only then
will they make a large concerted effort
towards changing that because I think in
the meantime they're just going to
slowly improve in the background and
just as they make more cars they'll get
better at it now when I do get around to
reviewing my Tesla while I point out the
panel gaps sure but I don't think most
people are there to see all right here's
my last hot take last one
is that 5G sucks 5G sucks right now 5G
is actually worse than 4G do you
remember the promise of 5G 5G was
supposed it was going to be this amazing
thing with this world changing future
we're gonna have blazing fast internet
in the palms of our hands everywhere we
go and it's gonna there's gonna be no
latency anywhere there's going to be
doctors doing robot surgery halfway
around the world with these magic gloves
that connect via 5G like all this crazy
stuff was going to be promised nobody
would ever wait for the buffering of a
YouTube video ever again and we'd have
the metaverse would finally be real all
these promises of 5G and it's turned out
yet none of that's happened none of
that's true yet now not even that is the
hot take I know that you know we
understand that it takes time to build
the infrastructure and it's just not
here yet like I did a video a couple
years ago now on the state of 5G and
what that meant and I would go up to a
cell phone tower and I would get
actually one gigabit per second down but
then you'd walk around the corner or
behind a tree and you'd get fractions of
that speed and it's like okay clearly
you need a ton of those antennas to
cover the entire world for that to be a
real possibility in the future and
there's no way that happens quickly
that's going to require billions and
trillions of dollars so yeah we're not
there yet okay we get it what I'm trying
to say is 5G right now is worse than 4G
it's slower it's less consistent and
it's more expensive I think we've seen a
lot of carriers especially here in the
US for example we've got T-Mobile
Verizon at T A lot of them especially at
T are using the low band 5G not even mid
band and low band 5G can actually feel
slower than 4G right now and on top of
that there's all these weird shenanigans
that they play with like the status bar
in your phone I've seen on the iPhone
like 4G 4G plus 5G 5ge 5G plus uwb all
these weird titles and none of them are
particularly encouraging I'll get a 5G
logo in the corner of my phone I'll do a
speed test it'll be slower than 4G so 5G
at this Point has really just turned
into a thing that smartphone
manufacturers can point at and be like
look our phones are new is this
something that we did that's different
from last year but really all it's ended
up doing is making our phones more
expensive because those radios are more
expensive making our battery lives worse
because now if you don't have 5G it's
switching back and forth and 5G is radio
and Battery consuming and making our
phone plans more expensive all at once
while giving us not that much of a good
experience so 5G sucks right now I think
also expectations are the thief of joy
and 5G really sucks because the
expectations and the promises were like
way up here and we're nowhere near that
yet 5G is brutally bad uh hopefully that
changes I want to be an optimist I hope
a lot of these things change to be
honest but yeah those are my those are
my hot takes right now here's another
hot take we have the best merch in the
entire YouTube game I'm wearing the
parallelogram sweatshirt right now
shop.nbhd.com as I wear the maddian
shirt right over it now I uh that's a
that's not a hot take everyone knows we
have the best stuff but anyway that's
been it let me know what you think I
promise the next video will be back to
your regularly scheduled programming I
hope to be in the studio soon fun
episode of the podcast just went up
check that out but in the meantime I
will see you guys in the next one
Bass
[Music]